this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction it's fine I'm fine everything's
fine
[Music]
okay I've got it are you ready yeah
Pur did it feel like that took forever
cuz it's the forever Purge I'm still
here but you get what the pun that I
made yeah forever I could have been
there I mean I could have watched a
whole movie from that to help the pun
but I just figured they might want me
here what voice are we doing today we
don't know we don't know it's my normal
this is my normal
voice you know what we also don't know
what's going on with this movie do we
have a purge daddy we don't know we just
know it's the forever Purge that is the
final movie of the franchise at least so
far all right Terra what purging this
time oh God she always asked me that and
I'm never
prepared um we are going to purge while
you're thinking about what to purge you
guys at home don't forget to like
comment subscribe and ring the
bell ring the bell exactly we want to
know what you guys have thought about
this purge franchise so far I'm pretty
into it I love doing these movies with
the Roxy it's fun I love these it's
Betty and Veronica it's I always Snow
White and the two girls in the
carala which girls are in the car felma
and
Louise Selma and Louise well it's Teran
Roxy Baby yeah we're doing it yeah we're
back we're doing it live actually it's
not live it's very edited and that's a
very good thing for us at the beginning
because oh my god do I make these
extremely long did you figure out what
you're purging no uh spiders I don't
like them
if somebody steps on a spider or purchas
spiders in this movie then we're
officially the happiest people ever
thank you so much speaking of the
editing to prepper for helping us edit
these videos if you guys are the sexiest
of super sexy people then you are
already a patron if you are not you are
missing out please go over there so you
can sync up with your own copy Greg and
John cover several shows over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included P got it one not a
fortress time but I am a Fortress are
you ready yeah I'm
ready if there's no perch daddy I'm
going be very upset going to be yeah I
don't think Frank Grill's in this but we
might have another Purge Daddy I hope so
or maybe it's a purge mommy oo I will
look forward to
both vast landscape no one to purge us
here desert exterior
daytime anytime we see places like this
in the middle of nowhere it's just like
how did this get there do you have
running water electri like how ises this
exist and why are there multiple people
there like they're all just but no cars
around y'all just been walking for a
minute oh they come this way they tunnel
folks love it I've never done any
tunneling I don't know that I should
want to do that but maybe it would be an
experience I think most people try to
avoid living in the tunnels yeah skip it
yeah skip totally I don't think
bucketless
material okay so something about the
Cel she's the mom of that
kid why did he run off like that I don't
know please don't start with a dead kid
yeah oh
what I do recognize her but maybe she
looks like Kristen Ritter's sister
yeah these colors don't run is that what
that said yeah on the on the wall the
what's that American bird the eagle yeah
the eagle American Eagle hey that's one
thing I got right you get a lot right
[Laughter]
babe
[Music]
maybe it's not her son maybe it's just I
know when she saying me yeah but I agree
maybe it's just like uh son son but not
illegal immigration On The Rise Mexicans
Fleet cartel violence seeking the
American dream one must ask is the dream
still alive no this a really cool title
sequence yeah the new founding fathers
immediately reinstate The Purge is the P
the the perch does stay true to itself
trying to make you think about where we
live and what time we're in I feel yeah
like this title sequence makes it feel
like this could be our tomorrow right
while it's like this dystopian time it's
also us yeah is once again right Upon Us
America divided by
y y h see I know this song Look at Her
Go not all the words honestly but
[Music]
text forever Street text forever why
does your brother have to prove himself
all the time keep call I got you I got
you will will I um
will uh you might be is that his name
but also this more horse than you
expected huh she's something too I know
someone who can calm that Beast okay big
actors yet again
[Music]
yeah listen his shirt has Pearl snaps so
I know he's going to do
[Music]
it he's jealous I know I can't think of
his name either I feel like it want to
say his name is Luke but I don't think
that's right I think I'm thinking Luke
there it
is
oh no that was cool no but horses aren't
supposed to lie down like that
right is it like cows where they can't
get up or is this how they sleep no he
they can get up okay yeah yeah
yeah let's get back to work he is the
true Horse
Whisperer make out make
out mhm yeah he knows how to whisper
horses and cook what a couple you need
to practice your English the talker
family would really appreciate that I
feel like he has perfect English yeah
you know and have a sister also an anny
you should meet her we don't need to
meet her sister we're fine what's
happening to his side the horse it's
really hard to find good health and
Anna's sister's a sweetheart we don't
need to meet Anna's sister Emily what's
up with the sister thing I don't even
know if I want our kids speaking Spanish
in this house oh got
it well he's got to go first but he
won't so racism so yes I assume even
though she's that's probably her sister
right
MH who would have thought I would be in
Texas I would succumb and go to the gun
store Kirk tells me that you're late
this morning I they were late sir hey
Kirk ju here says you're lying ju free
man say whatever he wants no why don't
you show up late again I'm going to have
to fire you he's never late why is he
such a jerk TT your Purge protection
bonus thank you Mr Tucker stay safe so
this guy Billy's good dude I feel like
he's nice right yeah he sees what's
going on Dylan believes a cowboy
shouldn't be from Mexico I don't know
either I always taught my son to be
proud American and maybe I didn't really
teach him what that meant America I
don't even know if I know what that mean
anymore proud American mhm good point
let's go dialogue damn Purge protection
bonus stay safe I feel like his son's
going to come for him in the purge yeah
that money's nothing but a way for these
people to Keep Us Alive so they can
continue using our slave labor for
nothing more than that I know what I'm
going to use my money for though and
it's not for protection booze you need
protection for that talking about
condoms yeah I mhm lock those doors set
those security systems and stay inside
for the next 12 hours and for those of
you who are partaking make God be with
you all why is that their is that their
logo for this I feel like somebody
graffiti that a lot of these shots that
rotate like that are making me super
Buzzy yeah I think that's the point
though they want us nauseous so that
they can Fortress Yeah we see that
America's reached a boiling point hatred
like that can't be contained you will
burn your cities to the
ground it's just not how TVs turn off
anymore I'm going to lock down now
y'all
also they do have lock down stuff out in
the country too that was crazy that we
kind of see his face as they were
locking down like yeah oh wow for the
barn too good don't you mess with those
animals or I'll lose it as I've said why
do you care more about the horses than
the people I just can't handle an animal
being hurt I can't do it do you eat meat
I do but I don't just checking in I
don't have to uh you
know kill it yeah
o
creeper some of the purge masks are so
creative yeah why are masks in general
so inherently creepy scary is it because
you don't know what's under it or is it
because what the actual mask looks like
both but mainly cuz the mass throws like
off I think it just like throws off your
senses of like that doesn't look normal
like a normal face so it's like I mean
obviously it doesn't look normal I'm
trying to explain the psychology behind
it but the words aren't coming Captain
Happ when the job's done know you're
good for it TT all
right hey are you clear on what they're
doing are they going to like a safe
house I I don't know because he just
said get one of the jobs done so okay
make yourself at home okay so yeah it
looks like it's just like a okay but
then the guards this is funny business
dude why is the guard a white male
starting y'all this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the annual Purge
sanctioned by the US government okay so
this is before this is okay before Purge
election then yeah cuz they're right
unless they went back after Purge
election to doing let government
officials be off the yeah at 7 a.m. when
The Purge concludes blessed be our new
founding fathers I like that they do
this for every movie though because if
you've never seen a Purge movie you
could still hop right in DN the rules
that's true
[Music]
yeah and this is all completely
different characters this could be the
first and only Purge movie you've ever
seen yeah true you might be a little
confused on the premise yeah and right
now I haven't seen any blue flowers so
we're not getting like the world around
yeah or you have to assum Texas and this
might be me being incorrect but you
would have to assume Texas would be Pro
Purge right
yeah he's so crazy
I what was that noise and what is wrong
with his side he's hurt
yeah they're in the pipes ooh he miss
spooky he missed it yes
sir look check your
cam this is jumpy for
sure
funny how like guys like him used to
play the protagonist leading man and now
in modern movies if you look like him
just immediately I think that you're the
villain which is just right is what it
is with his little combed hair uhhuh cuz
he's like the lead in so many romcoms
until now and then you see this and
you're just like you know this is an
[__] he's a bad guy
yeah H to weon Fortress I knew
it those long with bullets that's what
gets him
off bab okay Put the gun down why did
she go outside are I would have flipped
out at him if I was her he pointing a
gun at my pregnant self The Purge they
to dictate how we live our life this is
our country and we can choose to bring a
baby into a world of love why are you
laughing at me so they're not pro
Purge oh all right
uh oh they really just threw us into
that real quick what did we just witness
a bunch of unhoused people getting shot
in the street yeah need some a it's my
first birge is what you expected well
there's parts of Mexico that sound like
this every night we got a nice spot here
quiet I feel like an American wrote that
line got a nice spot here qu
[Music]
Qui three Bogies
inbound do not try to hide she just
picked up a weapon girl get it where's
the other guy who's supposed to be whose
weapon did she pick up this it was lying
there will no longer tolerate
foreigners and paging the United States
of America yes that is what they came
here to do America will be American
again see yeah
I shot don't you'll start a war and put
all your people in Jeopardy he will no
longer tolerate
foreigners and paging the United States
of America people homies just be making
[__] up all the time yeah oh God
absolutely and justifying really bad
things with their lives they leave their
own country they have to flee their own
country to come here to and right yeah
that's why that's exactly you know they
risk their lives to get here to do that
[Music]
does that mean it's already over the
last I think this was
this oh yeah yeah I didn't know if they
were doing a weird time thing where this
was to start oh maybe they faked it
maybe they sounded those alarms for fake
well but it's light outside though or
their lights on no there's no way that
like somebody would have been like wait
it doesn't feel like come maybe they
come to hurt them anyway regardless of
The Purge yeah ending you know maybe
they don't follow the rules of The
Purge maybe we do a time Jump to next
year yeah maybe this is Uncharted
Territory we have never done this in a
Purge movie we haven't we're very
confused you told us what the format of
every Purge movie was is that we're just
doing the night of the purge now all of
a sudden we're not doing that we're 30
minutes in all right end of act one
after the P you be a
holiday this holiday
holay oh no oh no what's gonna happen
are they going to get going to get hit I
don't know that's what it feels
like oh God is a coyote or wolf looks
like a wolf it's so
[Music]
big this is kind of interesting actually
we've never seen the aftermath and it is
the forever Purge so maybe The Purge
just never stops right The Purge is over
and now the cleanup has begun all over
the state violence incidents ended hours
ago is whoa okay yeah I think you called
it this doesn't
end so this must be post the election
one this must be the most recent in
terms of after the election one they
decided to go back to Banning hurting
those people CU otherwise we would have
heard about The Purge continuing right
yeah oh no people are hiding in there
yeah there's that one weird we saw two
we just saw two okay
is a goat
yeah if you saw a goat in a cage on the
street would you I would try to just let
it out right without it getting run over
I don't know I would think it was
somebody's goat yeah I you know what I
mean yeah I wouldn't let it out I would
think it was
somebody oh boy you are outnumbered that
is a lot of okay is it all his Cowboys
good question he said I know what I'm
doing with the money yeah buying a sick
mask to come take
over oh
no I don't know about that babe I'm
scared like is it going to explode or
something yeah or like crush the like
slice down on her head I don't want te
style oh I knew it
yeah what in the actual a oh waa that's
an insane
trap this is giving me saw Vibes right
now all right I get it go watch your saw
real rejects
reactions this bunny is
freaky she said help me to them you
think they're going to help you Bab yeah
I'm like look at them terrifying Purge
is over this is the forever Purge it's
never stopping huh
the oh my God oh my
God oh
yes hot Pur daddy save the day maybe we
saw him earlier walking with her they
work together I believe you're all going
to die no I think you're going to die
bunny boy yeah but is he allowed to hurt
them right
now well like what are the rules around
right
well I mean boss okay
yeah shite oh no didn't get them all get
it girl come on now oh no no no
yeah go darus
go oh taste your own medicine on your
need attack we didn't do anything the
perge is over lady what the hell are you
doing we didn't do anything wrong listen
to me listen to us
sir she's
like
[__] where's everyone oh no oh is it
going to be like the the guy hates them
but they're going to say have to save
him they're probably going to be the
ones that end up saving him I don't know
there the one dude oh No this must be
the cowboy right cowboy yeah oh that's
the crazy Cowboy yeah yeah yeah this
feels like Christmas any of y'all give
me a
present I spent your money well but
didn't he say it won't be on protection
these rich mother can't hide behind
their steel walls no more this the way
things are now boys this purge is
forever it would be a cool Halloween
costume
yeah run towards oh you got to be a
special kind of you'll have to pay oh
how much would you give for her Dylan I
forgot you're me now what you me you
have no money that's talk done without
money you can't save your own little
sister okay so now the guy that he hates
is going to have to save him and then
maybe he saves that guy's wife and then
the world goes round yeah got say I
really like the makeup artist on this so
yeah like his eyes look popped yeah
you're talking about life in America the
way to Rich get rich off the backs of
the poor the way it's been ever since we
robbed this land from the Native America
but you got no right to complain about
the very system your support by picking
up that gun and sanctioning the goddamn
turd [__] this is all
about one of the things I'm thinking is
might he die right now because he's the
most famous one in the movie and they
couldn't get him to shoot the whole
thing or will he's well he went out with
a pretty good monologue I guess from my
family to you go
yourself yeah you might be right about
that shot him yeah wow I was right you
were right and he went out with that
whole monologue yeah for a reason I
guess I really knew that you
did called
it I'm like okay we're halfway through
that means that they probably say they
shot this for a month they were they he
was like I will give you a week yeah and
then I got to get
out
[Music]
they
coming Forever After perch
okay come on that's a pretty shot I
shouldn't even be here I did nothing
wrong there's no such got to love a
swastica on somebody's face it's real
side do you think he's
on I know where she is this is the first
real
purge don't do drugs kids stay off the
shrooms when you're puron it's just so
hard when I don't know if he's a good
guy or a bad guy with the swasa on his
face like I just can't tell so I don't
know the a whole car of good guys yeah
maybe if they just reveal a different
tattoo yes
yes [__] it's blocked hold on well good
thing you're in a semi you know what's
tough is that like we don't like him I
know and I'm like but his dad say movie
where he's going to like realize that
those are his like true brothers and
they helped him and he needs to stop
disc change but there's no way he lives
no way yeah he's going to have to
sacrifice you go get your wife we'll
stay here and protect the truck you
don't need to wait for us yes we do I'm
coming with you what no you don't have
to do that yeah I do I saved Our Lives
and I know her from is it once upon a
time yeah you could be on to something
there
but that is a 30 odd
six word bro listen to that Rhythm that
is unck double bell
shotgun Homegrown Music from the
Heartland right there oh God she seems
like she's at a festival yeah yeah like
EDM oh yeah this one's been missing the
music that some of the other ones have
really yeah until
now
whoa that'll do it are we in slow motion
I think so move a slow motion for
oo that sounded like a neck
cracking oh oh boy I have to take care
of this
guy what
okay honey I would just start driving
but did you take this yeah but now his
sister's there I know it's tough I think
that's why story-wise they had her go in
because otherwise they would leave wish
they would have set her up having a
little bit more of a relationship with
the guys who did save their life but
that they'd been around forever and she
yeah to I don't believe then I would
have believe she would have gotten out
right he's about to get caught on the
feet I
think cuz we're staying up up up
[Music]
up like I was like what do you do he
just like hung the horn that's the only
choice right that got me that got
me o all right good shot
[Music]
there yeah like wouldn't he have known
that that guy had gotten out of the car
with a gun and was slowly walking around
a lot of the people in this universe
don't seem too smart yeah but also I
think they're just like so fed up with
the society that they're living in they
just lost their minds yeah I was
wondering like why everybody was
adhering to The Purge rules you know
criminals she's got to open the door and
help right I know she's pregnant but
open the door and shoot him yeah oh I
guess you don't have just roll down the
window yeah all right he's got
it I'm not trying to tell her how to
feel but I think she should look a
little
[Laughter]
happier oh oh this is not a good
position to be
[Music]
in did you kiss her like that's what
you're thinking about right now but we
we didn't how could we have known he was
a bad die right we had no
clues she's not had the easiest time in
America no she really
hasn't kick him in the yeah yeah yeah I
was like his legs are just right in
between him come on now
wa yes love a good just I wouldn't know
how to do that crack in the neck open it
up
oh I kind of thought that might happen I
should have said it out loud cuz now you
don't believe
me oh nice shot but before you shoot you
got to look yeah right cuz it could have
just your sister almost died not your
sister your sister-in-law get in the
TRU get in come on I need to get in my
family help you I move faster than my
own I'll be fine no dead here you Sav my
life thank you
Dar okay where is his family I we don't
know I don't think we've even met him so
he's like I I just don't know that that
was the smartest move on his part but
maybe I would have been like yo drop me
off in my family you guys Dro me off
like unless his family is right there
which maybe they were and we missed that
a world is on fire with passion and love
and actual
Flames okay so so far you were purging
spiders that hasn't happened quite yet
yeah know I'm sure there's been some of
the foreground we missed let's grab
everything we can peanut
butter oh they're in love that's why she
wanted to help cuz she likes cuz they
bone no they they're in love already
they bone already we think yeah for sure
for sure I'm scared to have my baby in
this world should be we're in this
together it's interesting choice to go
up to her and say that to her like she
is your therapist yeah got news what is
it Mexican president Leon Garcia Solair
and Canadian Prime Minister Sophie pues
are opening their borders for the next 6
hours oh so now they have to flee to
their country very interesting all right
okay Mexican and Canadian presidents
doing what nobody in the entire world is
currently doing for the countries right
we got to go to
Mexico it's going to be so interesting
for this mother yeah cuz I'm like oh
he's going to have to learn Spanish real
quick we will be ending our broadcast
here good luck America stay safe I'm
like but what happens when they get
there is it just going to be peaceful
and there has to be like a purge there
too or a place for them to go
realistically opening their borders in
Mexico and Canada like what would that
even do wouldn't the violence just Co I
don't know just move there right they
but I do like the premise of this being
like now you guys need to go you know
it's a good it's a good advice for the
movie but realistically it's like what
yeah you look like Mexican what are you
talking about one Let's uh what do you
say this uh slice the [__] cut the [__]
cut the [__] yeah but he speaks perfect
English it's so weird that they're doing
this yeah I got no problem with Mexicans
but I will say I don't understand your
culture just like you don't understand
mine I don't think white people any
better worse than anybody else we should
all just stick with our own just leave
each other alone I don't know if I've
ever heard that take from anybody like
what is the movie trying to state is his
opinion that he actually is racist but
he doesn't think he's racist yeah I
guess cuz it still is like stick with
your own and and I'm like yeah you're
you're making it seem like but he's the
one s stayed and waited for him after
saying stick with your own yeah and
that's not what his dad believed
obviously it's just an interesting I'm
always in The Purge movies they are
making political statements they're
making Society statements and what was
that statement they just were trying to
make it's weird cuz it's so different
from his like we don't need to meet your
sister that's that was like strong right
well I guess that's also stick with your
own yeah that's
true stop this truck
now
stay down everyone stay down what is
that what is she looking
at of
us that was easy yeah I was like will
they
really you go
Harper see you can't stick with your own
cuz they're in love
right it is also interesting we'll keep
our borders open for 6 hours right and
then they close it like what is if
you're in the middle of the country what
plan
man whoa all right that's an intense
shot I can't even this is such a woo woo
comment but I can't even believe we have
borders yeah right like it's yeah some
where you're born I know people in the
comments are going to lose it over that
sorry it's just wild wild concept that
we created them
just keep driving we got less than 3
hours please don't break down come on
baby oh God she's going to have her
she's going to be like my water broke
like what do you do if you're pregnant
and that does yeah I feel like that's
going to happen she's broke down come on
we got to get out just a few blocks from
here we can make it everybody you follow
on they ready stay oh so now they have
to get out all right why follow on did
one offer
that go go oh God just run
man oh okay was easy you
slip this is fil much darker yeah I'd
also be collecting the weapons on the
way she in a situation like this where
there's such utter chaos you don't even
know who you're shooting at like she
just keeps shooting and it's like could
be a good person could be a bad person
totally like how do you keep the borders
open too and then this is what's
happening yeah and there was like a
bunch of people just running where
you're like I've also never been to the
Border in Texas obviously I have many
times in California I'm kind of confused
on the layout of this like are are they
currently trying to walk across the
border yeah I think they're just trying
to cross
theater but like is the border that way
that way like which way are we trying to
go well I think we're try to oh Mexico
Arrow right now now I know yeah good
signage I think that's why it's all lit
up with those cars
except
yeah yeah the the cars are trying to
keep them from going
yeah damn wait did that just blow up the
theater that they went in that was shot
a little confusingly I'm not quite I
agree I don't think we're supposed to
know exactly what's going on okay
attention this area is under martial law
okay so it is kind of what I was saying
like once the US goes in for like
martial law and anyone who hasn't
crossed the border what are they going
to do is just zap them up like it's a
little confusing no I think the martial
law they're saying you can't keep people
from Crossing yeah okay I think they're
here there to try to help people get
across the government doesn't want
people to not get across right yeah it's
the people raging against the
government
yeah a real bad what who did that that's
like a weird prop
wait wait here
okay at least she knows how to hold a
weapon in a flashlight I enjoy that the
women aren't like remember how do I time
you said yeah yeah I did it wrong I did
it
wrong that's
creative let's get out of here you don't
think they're real people I mean that
guy I thought he was alive I thought I
saw him move ooh get
it oh good behind
you nice girl yeah reload [__] yes get
it Queen she said there are some Mexican
cities that sound like this all night
long oh members of
Road roses in the beginning follow the
with the card Mexicans leave signs all
over a city to help each other is
following them if we want to find our
wives we should do the same thing smart
yeah how come you know how to fight like
that I was part of the auto defenses a
group of women fighting the cartels we
did damage to them they first me and
Juan off her this is how we got here wow
yeah well we remember we know with her
kid with the yeah I like that she had to
explain it her kid but the son yeah yeah
with the cartel situation they were
talking about yeah yeah I think you're
right the US government it was the radio
people who said you can leave but the
government wants them to stay move I you
hand them over down drop your weapon
what is this nothing you can do drop
them you two Amigo the wives need to
come right now that a
boy but who are you guys exactly is this
Marshall L just I don't think so they'd
be uniform right yeah look what we got
here couple of bad ombres what do you
want to do about them daddy why don't we
give our fellow Americans here an
opportunity to redeem themselves you
kill thees and the two of you can live
that's some saw [__] help us purify this
nation once and for all that's what the
ever after Purge is all about they're
going to say yes but then they're going
to turn and shoot them love
it mother
gladly oh no and she loves him dang it
that's her lover yeah he's the one that
found the peanut butter to her jelly
yeah this is the NFA lay down your weap
you will be
shot back up back up back up Dam it
you're just yelling back up coming
baby oh they have backup too all right I
can't believe they killed that guy I'm
very upset yeah it's
sucks the green heue of this oh oh nice
got rid of her oh my
God oh my
God
sounds like he keeps calling her mother
he is like she called him daddy daddy I
know but I Daddy's like kind of normal
mother like like he's not calling her
mommy he's calling her mother probably
cuz they're incest babies I'm sorry yeah
for minute of Life they will be
here are you sure that this is safe cool
let's rage yeah I think it's time for a
drink
yeah
this looks like an Elk
Lodge we're on the same
team
stop okay all
right this is nk's Lodge I guarantee if
we looked up location they'd be like
they shot in a Elk's Lodge you
okay oh no she knows he's he's gone she
knows the El Paso border point will no
longer be open to United States citizens
fleeing the forever Purge Americans Left
Behind the's border wall are being
slaughtered by purgers oh God now
they're going to have to sneak across
the border for the first time in in
their American lives get out of the back
find CH Mo fast tell him to meet us in
the corner of Aman Island tell him if he
doesn't do this many people will die I
like her she works a lot I don't know
her name obviously she her voice is
awesome yeah follow me I know a way for
safety you just stand up and walk you do
[Music]
that it's like the government did this
to their own country by by doing The
Purge the thing that you and I both
thought was a good idea at first I know
right
know so
far now I've decided we have a purge
Mommy and it's her yeah she is Purge
mommy yeah
take us to Mexico please get him on
board believe
him oh they have to shove in that in the
back of that van I was wondering if he
was going to come back full circle yeah
imagine crossing the border that way
parts of the train those b d holes can't
build the wall on too dangerous we used
to makeig passage we'll take you through
some of you deserve another chance some
of you deserve another chance that mean
like I don't know what that means cuz
he's secretly going to try to kill like
the white people once they get there
Cassie we got to get you to Mexico I
know it's bad timing baby you'll be okay
it'll be help when we get across C's
help you TI
up that's not the girl from Lost is it
Claire Emily R A something no I don't
think so no I don't think
so
what are
they
okay yeah looks like we got trouble
coming beat your mother what is
[__] ichim
ichim
MRE oh it's this guy the Vengeance guy
ironically the other dude is a
mother
[Music]
Bingo she going to shoot them or what I
don't they're getting closed we need to
move yeah she's I love you I'll be right
behind you don't leave me stop the baby
I'll protect you get her to the medics
in Mexico put your
under oh interesting what is that I
guess it's like a motorized pulley a
pulley system that's cool we have a few
guns but when the bullets run
dry draw them in close use blades it's
not your fight we've been fighting this
fight for 500 years what does he mean
it's not your fight the point is we need
each other yeah wait for
it I mean they got to see them I hope
that they surprise them but these guys
got to see them coming
right
nice
okay cool
shot awesome those that's an interesting
weapon no
it's cool to do a movie that it's not a
white savior movie you know
yeah I mean Persian mom's taking care of
more than the rest of them I think but
even like you know before it was like
Frank gillow totally yes I agree
although at the end of that
one um like stamfield and all them
coming through that wasn't they yeah
that's their butts too see I guarantee
you she still got ammo cuz she doesn't
waste it oh no she's out dang it is he
smiling
no oh see I knew she'd at least have one
got it girl oh that
guy save it for the mother Daddy's got
to die he called himself Daddy and
you're not Purge Daddy no so you got to
go hunt him down and kill them all save
that Mexican son of a [__] for me Purge
and purify who that mask yeah that is
creepy wow how did they all get away
yeah I'm intrigued by that that they
were able to just run
off she has one left who she can use it
for Daddy exactly well I mean they're
coming it's got to be one all right he
oh the Rope he's going to cattle
them Dam dam she going to sacrifice
herself for something no but I do think
she has a plan or like risky something
she goes out there maybe pretends that
she's surrendering with then shoots
him they hot oh
cool
okay
yes all we need is one now we have a gun
rest of you go stop crossing the border
it's just like being pregnant is super
not ideal in
this
whoa wa that was a crazy
shot did he just hit that guy he just
ran him
over what
happened okay come on guys stick a stick
in the spoke yeah rope him off come
on
oh
no oh God okay white gu got to save you
now up wake up wake up okay wake
up dynamite there's a gun just there I
guess I was hoping she would like oh he
kicks it away now she picked it
up oh don't miss she's blurry if she
shoots her husband that will be the
saddest thing ever suck
oh no she got taken
shoot oh oh by Daddy this dude this dude
is such a all right now we got to rope
him and
awesome okay somebody use the horns I'm
glad a
this man is a g nice call your people
and tell them you need
help I want to see some cowboy stuff
though oh well yeah you got to save it
for Daddy
right be like call your people ask them
for
help what are you Su somebody did a
thing that I support take those weapons
I'll do it speak English I will cut your
throat yes
finally rope
them oh oh be careful with that gun
there yeah definitely shoot him I mean
for
sure oh all
[Music]
right again I love them so there are
good guys and there are bad guys and
that guy that they just killed was a
really really bad guy didn't matter that
he was a white dude he was a bad dude
yeah and that's what this guy on the
right Sky will learn yeah what's blonde
coover Cowboy name I don't know this
costum in the ankle she'll be
there I don't support that I hate that
why we don't know that it's like totally
safe I really don't like that
oh my God she delivered the baby oh wow
look who's
here thank
congratulations fake baby is not moving
at all at all such a
doll oh I knew they'd kiss of the nffa
has sent the military into every major
city and county the nffa is being
destroyed by their own creation yeah
yeah that's what I said all of the
United States as we once knew it may be
disappearing who knows what will the new
America look like when this all ends
looks all yeah
like yeah okay music though where was
music yeah we didn't have uh good music
drops in this like we did in the last
ones thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store
and is our gamechanging partner in
e-commerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new
heights Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
their awardwinning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com Regen all
lowercase shopify.com rejects start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix hul BL BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again let's see for once and for all
was his name Bill Patton that's what I'm
going to go with let's see all right
okay we got to I got to check it out
while I'm checking it out you tell me
how did the forever Purge stack up that
was our fifth Purge I actually really
liked it I think I liked it well uh the
last one right we said we you that we
didn't love it and you guys know even I
forgot Purge Daddy and I was you know my
brain but that was in the last one nope
it was in the second but I'm just saying
sometimes it takes a second for my brain
to catch up Will Patton Will Patton so I
said first I said will I think I started
with Will and then I turned to Bill y
bill is a nickname for William though
right yes okay so I was right the whole
you're close you're close she did it she
found it um uh
Armageddon yeah yeah okay and then we
got to oh and he's oh he's amazing in
silo okay great great and this other guy
is Josh Lucas and Josh Lu JH Lucas IED
callab oh and he's in Yellowstone also
yeah okay so there's just a lot going on
there's a lot going on Purge Mommy okay
so last one we didn't love this one I
like definitely better yeah me too I
didn't love I didn't love like some of
the exposition that they gave like the
pregnant woman and some of the stuff
that was going on
where um
thumb is that okay I think it is because
that's the
backup this thing is you guys at home us
non Tech Geniuses we're Frozen let's
just hope they're not frozen for you
guys okay keep
going I didn't love the exposition where
like especially when the pregnant
woman's like we got to get out of here
and then also uh uh white dude who's
married to her like when they're in the
van he's like we got to get you to
Mexico stuff like that bugs me cuz we
already know we're going to Mexico
and this other girl could feed
information while she's getting through
this creepy room with Adella protecting
her that part but there wasn't a ton of
exposition in it I really liked it I
liked um them the The Flipper roon where
obviously the people that he does not
like uh have to now save him uh and I
liked at the end where it's there it's
obviously going to form a nice
relationship the entire premise of this
I thought was good it they did a good
job of flipping it on its head where
it's just like you are sitting so pretty
here in America looking at people who
are crossing the border and looking down
on them like why did they do this
they're coming to our country right and
now when you need their help they're
welcoming you open arms trying to get
you there and it makes you stop and
think about your prejudices that you
have against people I thought they did a
good job with that with that one
character because they don't make him an
evil prick they make him ignorant and
they I'm talking about coover guy they
make him ignorant and they make him
unlikable but his he's like not going
around throwing slurs you know he
doesn't have a swastika on his face like
we just know okay this guy has a lot of
growing up to do like he's just not he's
not a great dude but then people can
change and through this through kindness
and love we do see him start to change
and I like that messaging I I think that
I love any movie that tries to unite
instead of divide and any movie that's
like one love and I think that
nationalism as a thing is kind of wild
that we've created these borders these
separations these divisions between
people between countries obviously I'm
speaking from an idealistic perspective
right now but like we're all human
beings that's the most important race is
the human race um and in this movie I
feel like they really tried to tackle
that issue and show like just because
you were born here doesn't make your
life more valuable and you can't just
close your mind to the fact that you
might love somebody of a different
country or a different race or different
religion you might need somebody of a
different background than you you might
Thrive with somebody of you know like so
of all of those things I feel like
because of that while this wasn't my
favorite of The Purge movies I think
that the first uh couple strong yeah one
two and three I I really like but the
reason I did like this more than four is
I really really feel like I got what
they were going for and they did execute
that now was there a lot of exposition
dialogue for sure uh did this have
purge's daddy going on no it did not in
the same way but we did have Purge Mommy
we got Purge mommy and I really like
that I did like that they made the two
women in this like strong where it was
like the sister's like I'll protect you
and she knows how to use a gun and so
does Adella the pregnant wife doesn't
didn't do too much but the other two
women did and they came through and I
like that but I like your suggestion was
with the sister-in-law it did feel a
little bit like I would have loved to
have seen her have they gave us some
glimpses that she's into this one other
dude and that's maybe why she's helping
uh the Mexican people but she for the
most part when she's like no I'm going
to stay and fight and were kind of like
what like we would seen that from you I
would have loved to have seen scenes of
them in the barn talking or like scenes
of them where we understand that she is
not her brother-in-law we do get that
moment on the table right so we know
that she doesn't have the same beliefs
as him with I got to introduce you to
this person or whatever but in general I
just I thought this was a really really
solid franchise and I think that this
did something really cool by not staying
on Purge Night yeah that was awesome
that you're like oh yeah what we have
said since the beginning of like this is
eventually going to bite them in the ass
right because why are people actually
following the rules that when the alarm
goes off and the sun comes up that
everybody just stops second and I'm like
yeah would that actually happen I like
that they explored that it it may not
people would get hip to it and go let's
continue it and on top of that what are
the ramifications what are the
repercussions of the Society of what
they've built and we haven't been able
to see that one time you know the most
that we have seen from any Purge movie
after The Purge is five minutes it's and
it's always happy it's just them
reuniting being like a lie making it to
the hospital or you know not killing
somebody and then making it to the
hospital like being having the moral
High Ground whatever it is we get those
five minutes and we see hope and future
and like okay to the next year but this
actually showed us for the first time
like this is [__] this is not helpful
and this is caused more division than
unity and something also that I thought
was interesting was how you and I were
kind of confused on what people's
positions were because this isn't quite
our world and it is a little confusing
because the government has set these
rules right yeah but then at the end of
the day the government is sending the
military to try to rescue people but
those are the same people that are doing
this because of the choices that the
government has made so at that point
those are anti-government people but
through all the other Purge movies the
anti-government people have been the
good guys but in this The anti- Purge
for one night people were the bad guys
so the people who were raging against
the government in this were the bad guys
as opposed to every other Purge movie
where it it was the good guys raging
against the government right right mean
because they're like we don't like The
Purge and we don't support it but now
yes now this one definitely flipped it
because it just became a a forever thing
and you can't really you can't really
justify like who's who like when they
were running away trying to get to the
Border we like now they are absolutely
[__] because you have no idea who is a
purger and who is just escaping because
everyone escaping and a purger is going
to have a weapon and try to defend
themselves at this point it's pure chaos
and the world is on fire which is why
that flag saved them um I mean at this
point I'd be like I wish there was a
Hobby Lobby I got a spray paint Purge
purification on me yeah but then you
might get killed by somebody who I know
who's like who's like screw you but then
I yeah I mean it's it's complicated yeah
that's what I did like about this this
was more nuan there weren't two types of
people there were a bunch of different
types of people people who had
previously been probably Pro Purge I
mean we did see that the wife the
pregnant wife was not pro Purge which
was interesting because I had said Texas
is probably Pro Purge but then we see
the pregnant wife who's like [__] The
Purge this sucks you know like don't let
the nffa tell us what to do yeah and
it's like oh okay so in our world is
that a liberal person right I assume so
but then she's the rich girl who is who
is part of that perpetrating the system
with the farming system so is this a
conservative so it was kind of cool to
see the Nuance of like not everybody
under different umbrellas has all the
same values you know and we you're
seeing that in our current world today
where like you might identify as one
thing but you it there's a it doesn't
mean that you have gray area yeah like
the over all arch of one specific point
of view doesn't mean it's everything
that you believe in exactly and then in
this when we're watching I'm like I
think I know what that person's about
and then they make different decisions
like with the uh white blonde Cowboy guy
when we were like oh screw this guy and
I was like he's not going to make it to
the end he's not going to live because
he's a douche and then it's like oh oh
he actually is ignorant and he is
adapting and learning and growing and we
do need to allow for people to do that
so while he's not as good of a guy as um
our two lead Mexican people the Juan and
um uh alah Al Adel Adela Adel a d e l i
feel you made a little sheep her
ad
what they called her as like those are
clearly our protagonists right those are
our Good Guys in this and he's not that
but he's also
not uh not mother mother and father
daddy mother weird guy yeah I think I
would have liked at the end because we
still got Exposition from other people
that if you're going to have that there
at least have maybe him at the end just
go hey thank you like a genuine thank
you to go like he we've seen him go with
it them it's probably made a change it's
not really confirmed I don't know but I
do think if we don't want him to be uh
to still have that like bad juice inside
of him going through all that I would
have liked to see him like thank them
did he do that did he say thank you and
I just like BL on earlier on he did when
he like kep the car but no I would have
liked the moment again at the end just a
a moment of like yeah and then the other
people don't say any like thank you back
it's just it's a head nod and it get get
out and we understand each other more
now I know that this isn't part of the
review as much but like what happens
from
here yeah I mean it's it's refugees in
Mexico yeah it's the flip of now we have
way more American refugees than we've
it's mostly always other countries and
now it's it's America's like burnt to
the ground and you know what's so funny
is that a lot of my Mexican friends give
me [__] when I say Americans because
that's not what they call us because I
guess like it's all it when we're North
America am your North America like to
them that is part of an America so it's
like the I guess the United States
people are or
refugees yes they like the same
continent yeah because it's in yeah I
get what you're saying just like they're
probably coming like America and they're
like yeah we're part of that too we're
all North America bro yeah yeah we're
all included you're the ones who put up
this [__] wallart border you freaks
yeah uh I would like a forever Purge
sequel to see what was going on with the
Canada Border yeah that would have been
that would have it would be cool to see
also to see like them having to live
without status I mean now the white
people who are in Mexico their status
and their money and their houses and
their cars and their gold is gone so
their whole way of living is going to be
new and I'd be so interested of like
you're now sleeping in a tent not not
that I mean she had her baby she had an
IV like they had it set up it's not like
they're gonna have you're not going home
to a house yeah no I would like to see
how they're going to live their life but
then yeah also how how did The Purge
happen in Canada I don't know so this
movie was in 2021 to me that me that was
so recent very recent that means to me
that there's not like a door closed on
The Purge franchise I genuinely think
that there's more stories to be told
here about post Purge putting it back
together going back to earlier purges
like there's just I this premise is good
not one of these movies has been a waste
of time no no no they've all been great
and they they always make us think on
like a a moral ground like an idea of
like what's the moral ground here what's
like right and what's wrong and why do
people live this way like it it evokes a
lot of thought all right I think we did
it we did it we purged The Purge we did
it did we forever Purge though I I hope
not because I would like to see some
more but how' you feel about the spider
situation I didn't see any single one I
mean I believe that they were maybe in
the foreground maybe just too small for
us to see it I think we got rid of them
I think we purged them yeah okay okay
thanks for being here with us guys uh if
there's another Purge we'll be back here
for that otherwise leave suggestions if
you want to see us cover a different
franchise or a different thing we'll be
back here anyway we will uh and and
perator it's a weird sign off I that was
good I don't think pilat works P perator
yeah they get
it all right John pick your name Andrew
Hayes Andrew Hayes you know what I'm
going to get you for Christmas this year
know Santa's delivering to you oh coming
down that JY he is delivering first an
operating table he hey you're going to
wake up strapped to an operating table
it's going to be there you're going to
think you're in some weird Nightmare and
you're in some sleep paralysis thing
that you just cannot get out of like I
need to wake up but ho ho ho no no
you're on the naughty list you're on the
naughty list this year as Santa is going
to uh surgically remove your legs
without anesthesia because anesthesia is
a sin for some reason yeah and he's
Christian Scientist he doesn't believe
in medication and he's going to make
sure your mouth is just really taped
shut so that would you can't even scream
man you can't even do it but he's going
to give you a new pair of leg so you're
taller but dude you're going to be like
what are those mythical creatures with
the Hooves the oh like uh like Mr tness
kind what is a Mr tness uh he's got like
goat legs goat legs on yeah those guys
fawn fwn yeah he's a f he's turning you
into a fawn and Santa's going to turn
you into a fawn you're going to you're
wake you're be taller be like whoa I can
see above the table and I can like run
super I run and then you take off your
jeans to see your new big thing and
you're going to be like oh my God Santa
gave me Fawn legs yeah and you're going
to be like oh no and that's the ironic
tale is you are now taller but you have
Fawn legs yeah so at what cost did you
achieve this height for and and the
ultimate mystery that we cut away from
to commercial break is like did he leave
your thing or did he give you a fond
thing and which one is bigger you know
well that's what the sequels for oh
that's right yeah it's Andrew trying to
find love his own kind so Andrew I hope
this holiday season you could learn to
adjust to your new life you could have
been just a paraplegic you could have
but now you got Fawn legs so i' say you
should have been ver uh so really man
you should have been a paraplegic man
you should have just said no Santa no
please just no I don't need the PA leg
keep my keep my stumps uh but really man
it's your call and I hope you have a
great Christmas with your family and
your hot mom and uh continue saving
people from getting their houses broken
in yes my fawn man
[Music]
yeah